winter is coming which means we must
always be warned and have constant
vigilance yes we need to build our walls
to keep DDoS attacks and data hackers
out so how do I keep my dragons or
better yet people in check from
releasing confidential data mobilize
dragon management uh or in Goudas Tom's
mobile device management 4G speed I
think we need to see your demo alright
let's jump into it
so this is how the c-suite admin console
looks like first you need to setup the
Apple push notification certificate in
the console to establish a connection to
the Apple push notification service
which is called popularly called the
APNs service so that G Speed MDM or any
other MDM for that matter can
efficiently send commands to all your
managed iOS device fleet to set it up
you download a certificate signing
request from the console uploaded into
the Apple push certification push
certificate portal by logging in with
your Apple ID you'll then receive a
signed certificate from Apple download
that sign certificate and uploaded back
in the c-suite admin console here you're
now ready to roll you can enable MDM in
the setup and can choose if each device
that is being enrolled needs to be
approved by an admin before it gets the
settings you can set a password policies
be it basic standard or strong you also
have some additional settings on the
device that you can control like you can
pick if notifications are allowed to be
viewed on the lock screen and if you
want managed apps to be able to sync
using mobile data or if you want the
user to be able to backup the device
with iCloud some Safari settings and
some specific settings around photos
screen capture and Siri now once you as
an admin have decided and applied all
these settings you want to enforce on
these devices you just have to turn on
device management send our
communications to your employees to
start enrolling their devices now let's
see what the user experience looks like
so this is my iPad I have my personal
Gmail on it to enroll the device you
first have to download the Google device
policy app from the App Store and then
once it downloads you log in with your G
suite at home this is my super-secret
password
accept the terms and conditions and
install the profile this is the G suite
MDM profile it takes a bit at this point
if you have required admin approval the
user won't see anything till the admin
approves this device as
for automatic approval though so it's
pretty instant we need to put in our
password one more time to sync email it
has synced Mele contacts and calendar
here in the native Mail app now let's go
check out our me this two accounts here
my personal gmail and the G speed-walk
account now let's say I lost this device
the G Street admin can simply wipe my
corporate email from the console sitting
in his office and ensure that all the
work data is safe here's the device we
just Android since this is my personal
device I'll only have the admin wipe my
work email and leave everything else on
there if it's a copy of device we can
potentially wipe the whole device to the
command has been sent going back to the
device you can see that there's only one
account now my personal one that's it
it's as simple as that
wow that was pretty amazing for sure
we're gonna win the throne with that one
it's only winning tones just as easy as
mobile device management with Google
cloud if you want to get in touch with
us go ahead and click on the link below
and if you like what you saw today
please like share and subscribe
[Music]